a lot of people were celebrating last
night and
understandably so it does raise concerns
though doesn't it to be
to be reopening things up to be opening
society and opening
the economy at a time when we know this
pretty dangerous variant is actually
spreading in the country
well look that is why we are taking
things one step at a time
uh taking things cautiously if you like
um we've
done the next stage of reopening the
overall prevalence of the virus is now
very low in this country there are these
hot spots particularly around places
like
bolton where the variant that was first
discovered
in india has been detected i know that
matt hancock said that we've done some
research into that variant the vaccine
does seem to be effective against it but
it does seem to have a higher
transmission rate and the
greatest defense we've really got is to
ensure that people continue to
get their vaccinations that we roll out
that program that people in those areas
who might have
chosen not to get the vaccine so far do
now get it
yeah i mean vaccine hesitancy actually
within that area and
amongst uh black and ethnic minority
communities does seem to be pretty high
at the moment i think the uptake in in
in one particular area affected by this
variant is 37
which is just not good enough is it how
how do you begin to really now tackle
that hesitancy issue
well we've been doing a lot in recent
months to get those communities who are
a bit more hesitant to
engage with this program to have the
vaccine
i think maybe in those areas when they
see the resurgence of the virus
it may prompt them to think actually
this is serious the vaccine is effective
it is preventing the spread of this in
other areas so now let's
uh now let's get it and we we just need
to keep redoubling our efforts
in some of those hard-to-reach
communities to get them to see that
having the vaccine for all of us is the
best way out of this terrible pandemic
oh do we need more
sort of voices from the these affected
communities
to come up and speak do we think well a
lot of work is being done in those
communities and it has been
you know quite effective in getting
uptake but yes there are still
pockets where uptake is low and we
there's no shortcut to this we've just
got to
to redouble our efforts to get uh
community leaders
uh faith leaders in some of those bame
communities
uh to really encourage people to come
forward and have the vaccine
where are we in terms of the whole
vaccine process i know it's gone very
well for the age groups that have been
that have been targeted so far but this
highlights doesn't it a need to get this
process
sped up to an extent well we've been
running it at a phenomenal
rate to be honest uh we we now have
close to 70 percent
of the population have had their first
job
approaching now i think 40 percent have
even had their second job
we've uh reduced now the time scale
between those two from 12 weeks
uh initially now down to eight weeks so
that we can
speed up the roll out of that uh second
jab because we think that with this new
uh variant discovered uh first in india
that there is
uh additional protection if you like
from that uh
second uh second job and the second job
becomes more important so
we're trying to condense those scales
and get the second jabs out as soon as
we can
i was talking to quite a quarter
yesterday and he was saying
that it is he thinks still very likely
that
the next stage of of lockdown easing
with the full lifting of everything
on june 21st could still go ahead i mean
are you as confident as the business
secretary well i we want it to go ahead
uh there's a whole plan about it
of course but we cannot rule anything
out and and that is why the prime
minister said we will take this a step
at a time
as we uh have one set of easements and
just yesterday we've
uh had a further set of easements opened
more parts of the economy
we need to see how that beds down over
the next two to three weeks
and then shortly before the 21st of june
we'll be in a position to assess
whether we can go to that uh next stage
we want to do that that's always been
the plan
we want each step to be an irreversible
step but we can never rule out that
there may have to be a delay i mean
with that in mind is the government
actively looking at
you know opening fully opening on the
21st whilst imposing if necessary
local restrictions on areas that are
still struggling is that an option
that would be an option and we cannot um
rule anything out obviously at this
stage
but our preferred our preferred outcome
is that we
really double down and get the
vaccination rates up in those areas that
are seeing
uh these problems so that we can give
them the immunity that they need to this
virus
and then we won't have to have any such
local lockdowns now
again talking to quasi quatering
yesterday he wasn't particularly in
favor of the idea that certainly in
places like bolton and blackburn
they seem to be should we say bending
the rules a little bit
on who can be getting vaccinated finding
a reason to vaccinate anyone who wants
to come forward
what's your view on that because if that
is going to tackle the problem and these
are
worrying hot spots don't we just need to
get as many people
jabbed up as possible well we do need to
get as many um
jabbed as possible but also the the
advice that we have from the joint
committee
on vaccinations who who advise us on
this is that if you
divert effort to vaccinating very young
cohorts people in say their 20s
at the expense of vaccinating those in
their 30s or 40s
if they've got you are risking them but
if they've got the supplies if they've
locally got the supplies
it's not necessarily a bad thing is it
well i mean there will be
lots of already cases where if they've
got supplies and they can do it then
they will push people through
faster but to have a conscious decision
to say vaccinate the whole population in
those areas
uh when actually there are still many
people in the cohorts of
uh you know 35 and above who've maybe
not had the vaccine
the right thing to do is to get those
over the age of 35 to have the vaccine
since
it's the older you are the more at risk
you are i'm just in tree you say 35
my understanding is it's currently 36 at
the moment
is it dropping down to 30. it's dropping
it's dropping regularly i think it's not
today
uh i don't think it'll drop today but
it's uh and you know but i i don't know
exactly what the update of the break
but it's moving all i'd say is on a
almost a daily basis moving down
the age range yeah look can we talk
about brexit a little bit i mean we we
have to be very careful
don't we about brexit now that with we
you know we've we've gone past all these
hurdles
we have to be very careful don't we that
any trade deals that we're now working
on do not
negatively impact groups in the uk i
mean particularly
hugely important groups like the british
farming sector
well and that's always the case in all
trade agreements um
you you go into these we we think it's
great opportunities
we're very keen for instance to pursue
trade agreements with uh
australia and also with the united
states and uh with other countries uh
as well and um but always in any trade
agreement yes there's a balance to be
struck between
uh you know your commercial interests
and your your desire to open up free
markets
is there a danger then with for example
australia if there was a free trade deal
that would potentially negatively impact
the british farming sector wouldn't it
well there are huge amounts of things
that a country like australia produces
that are currently subject to
tariffs because that's what we had in
the european union
but we're actually we're not even a
producer and we can
offer them terror free access in those
areas everything from nectarines to
almond nuts where they're a big producer
and also of course wine
what about the areas where we are a
producer well it's a
standard thing in any trade agreement
that where you have what are called
sensitive sectors that's
uh particular areas where there might be
economic impacts to having a trade
agreement well there are
well-established ways to to manage that
where you can have
what's called a tariff rate quota as if
you like a tariff free envelope and a
set volume so there's ways of uh dealing
with all of these things
but is it is it right that the
international trade secretary is pushing
for a zero tariff
uh approach with australia across the
board
well look i'm not going to get into uh
you know discussions that are going on
in government about individual trade
agreements no you're not happy though
are you oh no
in any uh discussion on any part of
government policy and trade agreements
are no exception there's a
there's a discussion and there's a
consensus and at the moment there's a
very clear consensus in government that
we want to do
a trade agreement with countries like
australia but obviously on the right
terms is it fair to say then that you've
had some
robust discussions as reported in the ft
today
i have uh very good discussions with all
of my cabinet colleagues on
all issues where we've got a shared
agenda
i think the smile says it all is that
that's for the fair assessment
no i mean of course um in any um
discussion on any part of
government policy there will be uh
issues where different government
departments have a
uh shared interest and um you know we we
obviously have a discussion in order to
establish a consensus
okay um looking post-pandemic
how do we start to to properly rebuild
the economy it's going to take a lot of
work
how do we rebuild the economy and
rebuild it greener
well um we've been setting out today and
i'm doing a big speech
later today about nature and the
environment we want to put a much bigger
focus on nature so we are announcing a
strategy on peat which will include a
ban on the sale and use of
horticultural peat in garden centers and
a really big ambition to treble the
amount of
trees that we plant